oh wow you're on your reality check tour
you brought up will smith's slack in
your stand-up act have you talked to
will about the incident uh yeah i mean
look will will is apologetic he's in a
better space of course than what he was
after people are human and as humans
sometimes
we make mistakes life goes on and people
grow so give an opportunity to do so
that's good perspective from kev who
spent last night with his buddy dwayne
johnson at the premiere of dc league of
super pets an animated film about a
group of pets with super powers fighting
to save superman
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me this is the fifth time we're
seeing you and kevin hart team up
together this is the fifth time in the
last time that we did no i love kevin i
love kevin and we always have the best
time on screen off screen tv night with
my pro the rock and kevin are joined by
their hollywood pals john krasinski
vanessa bear jamila jamil and keanu
reeves in the superhero comedy hitting
theaters july 29th why does it work so
well between dj and kevin they have a
nice kind of
free zone
and really good heart is there a
favorite co-star of yours from the past
that you would love to team up with
again and again and again like the two
of them have alex winter this makes more
villain tech
and circling back to kevin check out
this special shout out my brother from
another mother nick i love you man has a
heart of pure gold and to know him is to
love him which is what i do the only
positive message you ever get from me
you got a prank coming you son of okay
[Music]
you